okay great just a couple of super demure
outfit okay like it's different now I'm
here with mamrie Hart I'm kind of burped
while doing it it sounded auto-tune if
you guys don't know what you should know
by now because it's very much common
knowledge memory and I have a podcast
called this make it weird
I wore my first song a bathing suit you
watch news release every Wednesday it's
like a caged animal that gets released
it built it up we pocoyo my Prada and
then we release it to the public and
we've evolved it so much to a point that
we are now going on tour we are going to
seven different cities let's see if we
can remember which ones they were Dallas
I know double D's joy Detroit Phoenix
Minneapolis Seattle Portland that's it
that's it back to live in a tour all the
links for the tickets are down in
description box below so please go get
those not to toot our own horn but I
feel like we cultivate an audience of
really sweet wonderful open-minded
people that all want to meet and greet
each other so I think it would behoove
you to go out on a limb and do something
you're uncomfortable with and maybe come
to one of our shows by yourself and make
some friends you don't use both enough
our podcasts a lot of it is gray tonight
going on adventures and I and I do a lot
of those by myself so like what better
time to go do something fun by yourself
then the podcast back celebrates that
you start your own podcast based on
coming alone to our live podcast but
don't be a direct but please we need all
the sponsors I will kill you like the
nap that just landed in my drink we talk
about a lot of random on the podcast and
one of the consistent topics that comes
up is family sawa devon Sawa was one of
my main crushes obviously as a youngster
jtt was number one the bretton Sawa
I like GGG I thought wasn't it more
attainable
he was ok cuz he was sure he was closer
to the ground he was grounded he was
mainly TV besides a couple movies so I
just thought he was easier to access as
an 11 year old living in North Carolina
this is pre Twitter this is all we had
Devon solo it was like this magical
beasts and now he's grown up he's a
family man and he's all over Twitter and
Instagram and he's really funny we have
found a very sorry I got mosquito anyway
devon Sawa has become someone that we
have accidentally not so accidentally
become more obsessed with and talked
about a lot to the point that he's
started liking memories tweets we are
really manifesting this human into our
actual world with that comes the future
impediment Sawa the Siwon is Elmer Fudd
latter crush on Devon so long it was
that all of unfussy one fuzzy mom
another unicorn in the social media
atmosphere that is fascinating to us she
is 16 has the voice of I thought it'd be
a very fun video idea to do Sawa or see
wha I'm gonna show mamrie very close-up
images of something and she has to tell
me if this has come from Greg Lee ozawa
or Jo Jess god this is our baby buggy
bumper or Josie was instagram sponsored
by wah-wah here's our first image oh my
god that looks like me do you want
doesn't have her lips done and this
clearly wouldn't be Devin Sawa's lips is
it pictures of them are just pictures
they posted a picture
they posted because Sawa you will find
he loves a good meme he does love me I'm
gonna say this is someone posing with
Jojo co-op we were corrected Jason David
don't break Joe Jesse while the action
is honestly like wow this is crazy Lal
I found three new friends today fire
emoji I love these people today this so
checks out Congrats
one for one no okay now Devin I hope
Devin routinely posts his kids who are
Rec really cute many has a really
adorable little daughter so I'm gonna
say this is from Devin Sawa's Instagram
it's a picture it's like a Halloween
photo or like a birthday theme photo
famous kids are you are correct my
three-year-olds birthday so we hung a
unicorn and beat the SH out of it with a
closet rod the saw was no Victor truly
no filter on there is next really my god
is an Auburn breadstick but no I'm
hungry think it's Jojo see wha see you
off final answer it is to close their
eyes and really concentrate on her wish
look at that should have known that I
should have known it's like a little sea
creature with eyeballs of all pointy
nose okay um I'm gonna say it oh man
it's part of Jojo si la Freddie Mercury
costume since she had a queen themed
16th birthday and made everyone listen
to her sing Queen so you're close it is
L Brianna it
there was a musical legend in there
somewhere
I love that Elton's titty looks like a
secret joy and they are both killing the
glasses game okay Wow okay
okay I think this is a classic devon
Sawa meme
I think it's an animated picture you are
clear at night is the segue in which
Jojo see well brides in her life show
it's called Bobo trust me I have to
watch the video footage so I knew that
this wasn't photo shoot right yeah it's
a segue that's feathers all the way up
and then this is on the front of it this
is not photoshopped that's like a face
and she rides it all across the stage
while she sings we have to go to this
tour also if I was Jojo co-op when I was
touring I would name it take a bow like
take a bow Maddie what I'd name my tour
okay that's our life next I um I feel
truly grace Helbig hold on I don't know
what this one is got it somewhere in
here you've thrown in a devon Sawa
classic mean so I'm gonna say it's a
John wick meme posted on Devin's I
wasn't yeah you were correct a few
minutes ago it was Jojo see watch
singing with the Queen cover band Queen
nation the Queen tribute band you know I
was doing a 16 dead drop drugs my mom
handle of pop off vodka in my trunk when
we went crazy all right here we go sawed
off its do a lot of complaining about
gasoline prices it's such a dad a full
bag I gotta wear it can we figure out
where is it I mean it's in Hollywood see
you all that's part of a costume this
shoulder has a martini on it girl there
we go that's uh those are teeth um I
wouldn't put it past Evan Saul watch a
post and Ace Ventura I mean he
absolutely has posted Jim Carrey on his
Instagram however this is Hollywood
that's our Kanye West II oh my god you
know what I bet North is a Penelope are
obsessed with Jojo - Maury I mean this
close-up is ridiculous waiting for the
birds to use my new bird feeders
honestly though I got a new hummingbird
feeder chip goddess won and I was just
like waiting as well okay I swear we
obviously with that kind of hot pink
it's a song to see one I forgot what
it's a Jojo see what it is incorrect
devon Sawa in the background with this I
love this house you sent me this toast
on a DM on Instagram that said I don't
know what to feel because he is
extremely attractive and being a family
man in this photo if I was eight I have
a crush on the son
well baby I think you passed the test
I don't know if there's anything curve
on this at all the one you guys should
buy tickets to our live shows if you are
in or around any of the available cities
that we are doing it in all the links
will be in the description box below and
now go over to main which channel
because we are doing a video over there
in which we talk about celebrity riders
and other than that listen to our
podcast every Wednesday this might get
weird and we have a patreon all the
links are down below it's really fun
over there I mean I feel like you need
to step up my Instagram game Laurell and
boob if you haven't give like a logline
for each one of them people that don't
know devon Sawa Sawa
if nineties heartthrob turns adult [ __ ]
sound and then Jojo see wah is scared